zur heutigen video ich bin heute nicht
alleine sondern mit zwei weiteren leuten
die kennt eigentlich keiner rechtlich
auch gleich auch den genau gleichen sind
wie beim twin von worldwide wurzeln ja
als antwort haben wir euch welche
bereicherung titel wer ist der
schlimmere youtube wir haben hier
aufgeschrieben und entstehen die namen
von sogenannten huthi youtube wir ziehen
eine schlimmere vergehen und dann machen
wir eine abstimmung online auf einem
kutter kanal und wenn er lügt sagen
können einfach zum allerersten mal die
durch beiden jeweils eingesehen und laut
vorlegen
ich starte dann die umfrage die mama
okay wir überlegen erstmal ich
persönlich finde die man bei derart auf
twitter schon immer was los gelassen so
aber leonard in diesem fall wird der
ganze attraktiven game gebracht unter
anderem maschinen wie der partner
[Musik]
mittlerweile 83 prozent abgestraft ich
gar nicht erhalten
der straffe übrigen müsse beherzt
schlafzimmer werfen und jedem einen
bereiten nicht nur ein einziges buch
gibt
zb alle youtuber während rapper und 15
minuten am tag einfach einige wirklich
gesagt hat das ja auch einige videos für
den channel von damit die unbedingt
vorbeischauen
natürlich seien erstmal in die
abstimmung
kommentiert london bremst
findet ihr sohn sie nur interessanter
machen also der schwimmer ich finde ich
würde mal sagen
noch schlimmer für youtube etwa ist
nicht gerade glücklich gemacht sich
nämlich wir sind auch für meine meinung
mit klammern kann passieren aber ich
habe noch gar nichts
wir haben hier einmal mehr
okay wir haben
[Musik]
ganz kurz ab
wenn ihr noch mehr sehen wollen
wir haben wir einmal
[Musik]
huggel steht wieder zwischen klavier
verfehlt wir bestehen
hier wachsen schwerreichen hilfen okay
leute wie aktualisieren
die finale runde und grafite 26
[Musik]
man hat einfach damit einfach nicht
weniger